pour revenir à ces journées mondiales de
la jeunesse de pour la première fois à
la demande de monseigneur lustiger
l'église catholique s'habille haute
couture c'est jean charles de
castelbajac qui a conçu bénévolement
tous les vêtements liturgiques pour les
prêtres les évêques et le pape des
créations vous allez le voir très coloré
le reportage d'eric guéret et marque sa
vidéo
la liturgie inspire les créateurs et ce
n'est pas jean charles de castelbajac
qui nous démentira le célèbre couturier
a délaissé strass paillettes et
mannequins habillés en toute simplicité
prêtres évêques et le pape jean paul ii
des vêtements multicolores symbole de
diversité culturelle
pour moi c'est comme des les formidables
oriflammes du ciel pas cessé c'est la
couleur comme ciment d'espérance et il
estime enthousiasme ce n'est pas que
l'idée cette réunion dans les jours qui
viennent et aussi tous ces petites
graines de couleurs qui vont repartir
aux quatre coins du monde
un simple tissus blancs marqués d'une
bombe de couleur rouge jaune bleu vert
orange pour marquer les cinq continents
les vêtements liturgiques évoque la
modernité et l'espérance c'est en tout
cas le sens qu'a voulu donner le
couturier
la mode elle est là pour inspirer et la
fouace dire
donc je pense que la mode est un
instrument formidable pour parler des
filles jean charles de castelbajac a
travaillé bénévolement pour les journées
mondiales
pas question pour lui de récolter un
centime de cette opération
n'en déplaise à ses détracteurs sa
démarche est avant tout spirituelle
si on peut marquer un certain moment
cette renaissance de l'art et du sacré
et ben je crois que là on aura lui ni
vraiment un vrai salaire et que le
travail de bénévolat sera chèrement payé
jean charles de castelbajac rêve d'un
retour à l'art sacré d'un travail
conjoint entre le clergé et les
créateurs pour que l'église parle mieux
d'elle en pleine lumière